this is a production of Cornell
University
this Apple dome has been growing quite
well for the last few years so naturally
it needs a little maintenance trees and
living sculpture need guidance to
maintain a form they can be pruned
grafted and woven together to make any
desired effect with this project I like
to focus on weaving because these
lateral branches are a little too small
to graph together and weaving will help
fill out the walls of the dome an
advantage that these branches are so
thin because it actually makes them a
lot easier to weave together
the lower half of this dome is a lot
thinner because it's been browsed by
deer to stop this I'm installing a
temporary deer fence until we can build
something more presentable
you
you
you
and
leaving is just one small step in the
development in this sculpture this Apple
zone is exemplary of the progressive
nature of working with a living medium
while it's important to plan in advance
flexibility is crucial
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu